dude I would get these really annoying
comments like from the wild and out days
where like just random dudes on forums
would be like no attempt to sell out
because he gets on that show and lets
everyone make Asian jokes to him like
what are you supposed to do is talk him
I'm like yeah what are you supposed to
do fight everybody
[Music]
I'm just gonna play this for you
basically there was a commencement
speech at Purdue oh I saw that and the
chancellor said something pretty funny
let's see what you guys think of it you
told me what he said yeah you'll love it
actually Nick you'll be a big fan oh no
oh no well all I can say is
oh [__] bro
that's that's sort of by Asian version
of his uh what do you say
you want us to translate yeah what do
you saying oh wait he didn't say
anything just gibberish Cantonese
he did a good job though like it wasn't
bad wait what's the contest is Joe
approved
why what the [__] is he doing that for
what is the concept so there is actual
context
we should just leave it dude
hey just to close this out what's the
best part is look at look at how many
people behind him like laughed at it and
we're down with it you got good
reactions from the crowd
that came out of nowhere dude what the
[__] is that guy doing so the context
the context to be fair and this doesn't
exactly exonerate this but like the
context that somebody had a speech right
before him in which they were saying
that while they worked on a radio show
they used to speak in this made-up
language and I guess he was trying to
emulate that and what came out just
happened to sound Asian so he just kind
of tried to save it with all that's my
Asian version of whatever he just tried
to make a gibberish language so what he
have not been in trouble if he didn't
say Asian he was just saying like oh I
was just referencing that yeah but it
just like it sounded Asian it did but he
was really you don't have to say it yeah
he was just trying to like make a
[__] [__] up you can't do that at
a graduation man
why would he do that it's so dumb it's
so funny it's funny because he was so
full out that dude had no inhibition I
mean we're upset here at JK we don't
condone the seven no we're not the
[__] next shark comments
that [__] was [__] stupid I'm
laughing at how crazy like ridiculous it
is have you guys ever been when's the
last time you guys been to like a
college graduation like last year yeah
and when you're up when you're at a
college graduation you're like there
needs to be way less people talking yeah
they talk too much it's like have like
one or two speakers that's it it's like
plus clothes with a punchline like this
he needs a headline
why people are mad though because it's
like it obviously sounds like he's
making fun of uh some type of Asian
language right right sounds Cantonese to
me the context helps but I'm like come
on bro like why why is that where his
brain goes
and it's like shouldn't you know better
at that level in this field and not the
position yeah that's supposed 90 years
old dude but it's supposed to be an
academic intelligence like celebration
it's Purdue like in a [__] Cypress
College
I actually would like a world though
where that's okay and then the Asian
Professor that comes on can go by
[__] hell oh [__] like well this is
that the equivalent let's just be
embrace it yeah embrace it yeah like all
the jokes can fly everyone can say
whatever the [__] they want let's just
clown the [__] out of each other Indiana
Indiana
Purdue University's in Indiana can I
hear it one more time yeah
it's funny because it came out of
nowhere and the Devil Went full force
y'all
did say that like racism or something
has been a problem there is reasonable
yeah or no hey making it too real man
holy job
Purdue there's like a racism problem in
Indiana Oh I don't know in America maybe
I'm mixing up articles I don't know but
I I could have sworn I'm sure that's
fair to say yeah like one of the
students or one of the faculty was like
see that's just one of the many examples
like this goes around all the time
whether it's in the faculty rooms or
whatever I mean for me I'm like are you
surprised these fools look 80 90 years
old and their humor all that [__] is
like they're probably still laughing at
Minstrel [__] like they're still
laughing at old ass comedy like thinking
like it's still funny you know I mean
like not that excuses it but I expect it
I expect 90 year old dudes to be dumb
and [__] races as [__] he did already
apologize for it but he said it was
taken out of context which is like
that's what happened how do we put it in
context then like the context help me uh
not be upset as much like it's still
like it's like come on it's like it's so
stupid it's stupid right but it's like
okay you telling me what what led up to
it yeah there's a little bit of a thing
yeah you [__] up but you're also like
60 years old bro
these fools look old dude I don't know
what his age is but he definitely looks
you're old enough to know that like this
is a little wild bro these fools are old
enough to be like man I don't like
segregation and I mean I I I wanted a
segregated school like that's how old
they are right I mean for real they're
like I tried yeah I try to keep the
blacks out you know like though that's
that's they're still that age right
right but it's the it's the Laughing of
the dudes behind him dude they were
killed bro yeah the fact that yeah
that's true
Chinese people do sound like that that
was better than last time it's the
natural reflex of like this dude's
killing it or they're like they're like
you should have seen what he was doing
last night yeah that ain't nothing yeah
like oh Bob's all right isn't he I know
but you would expect at a graduation for
it to be like dead silent after
something like that you would think but
he got some laughs dude yeah hey dude he
cleared the room with that [__] well I
mean contextually they weren't making
fun of Asians though like they were just
oh that's true yeah they were making fun
of a weird like a made-up language right
well I think the second he said that's
my Asian count that's when it became
making fun of Asians yeah if he would
just be like if he would have been like
this oh okay there's my made-up language
right instead of being like Oh that's my
Asian version then it's like oh yeah
yeah because then everyone's like oh
that sounds Chinese but he doesn't know
right I feel bad for the kids because I
think for us we've been through all of
it and we're like oh this guy's just
stupid you know but then for the kids
when they're all young and stuff and
right after the graduation imagine how
many more times they've heard that on
the way out into the parking lot the
white homies
yeah
yeah and that's the issue you're right
you're right right yeah now they're
gonna hear that maybe all of next year
too yeah I do like that from from the
outrage over [__] like this context or
not people are more like they get that
doing that is like
something you don't do you feel me like
making fun of an Asian language like
with the ching chongs and [__] it's more
like now if you read comments people are
like
oh that's not cool you know what I'm
saying as before it was it was just
everyone was like oh this is a funny
thing yeah yeah yeah and then like and
then like because now even like I
remember watching some of the stand up
back then that I watched I just saw on
like on whatever and uh even back then
feeling like God this is such a a cheap
easy joke yeah it's hacking yeah
and but now you know people know that
like hey you know what this is uh we
find this offensive guy so it's like
they don't even do it right my favorite
one that'll always get a pass though is
in rush hour too after Jackie Chan or
after Chris Tucker finds out Jackie Chan
and Don Cheadle have like the same uh
Master yeah or like uh their Master
Brothers he tells them like all this
like talk [__] about Chris Tucker or
whatever like in Cantonese he walks away
Chris Tucker though
yeah look all the rush hour jokes get
passes bro for sure
everybody gets it everybody gets it so
then it's okay and the context is them
learning about each other you know what
I'm saying yeah they end up being better
people yeah it makes sense the bit about
Chris Tucker saying like you guys Asian
people be freaking out all the time and
he's like no Chinese people are very
confident he's like not when Godzilla
comes around
he's like I'll be going crazy that Don
Cheadle [__] that scene like me and
chill actually quote that teacher all
the time
Chris Tucker's voice it's just it's all
that's just hilarious right he just sell
them so but at the same time I [__]
slap you back to Africa
plus there's no power dynamic in that
relationship yeah it's like they're in
it together it's fish out of water in
the same bucket it's not like oh this is
someone up here and this is someone down
there just getting dunked on dude I
would get these really annoying comments
like from the wild and out days where
like just random dudes on forums would
be like no attempt to sell out because
he gets on that show and lets everyone
make Asian jokes to him like what are
you supposed to do is [__] him I'm like
yeah like what are you supposed to do
[__] fight everybody do you not watch
literally 10 seconds later when I clap
back and I [__] like own everybody
like what the [__] are you talking about
I'm up there like we're going back and
forth I'm like literally like defending
our people up there and what like what
are you even saying but that makes you a
[__] that like to get all riled up and
go wait a minute [__] you guys you hurt
my feelings like that actually makes you
look even worse can you imagine if he
did that yo DJ Cut the music why'd you
say that
do you not understand what my people go
through when you say things like that is
that is that a bell is that a bell or a
buzzer
everybody all these like AO team's about
to leave again
he's gonna storm out
oh my God the better thing is to keep
cool play along and then [__] destroy
them in the game yeah man I mean yeah
yeah you did that yeah well you know
thanks man yeah thanks buddy
foreign
[Music]